we all know the s p 500 as one of the
safest stock market investments in the
world the index is regularly updated to
reflect the top 500 most profitable and
stable companies in america so you can
be pretty sure that as long as america
is still growing the s p 500 will be
growing as well but despite the
ubiquitous nature of the s p 500 most
people aren't aware of the company
behind the index sndp global aside from
deciding who stays and leave the s p 500
sntp global manages dozens of indices
with the focuses on various regions and
sectors such as the snp asia 50 and the
sntp midcap 400 snp also specializes in
providing companies and governments with
credit ratings in 2011 for example snp
downgraded the us government from aaa to
double a plus considering all these
background roles of snp i don't think
you'd be surprised that snp posing quite
a bit of money in fact they're the 153rd
most profitable company in the world
with a market cap right around 100
billion dollars so here's how snpp
global became the king of index funds
taking a look back the history of snpp
global circles back to a man named henry
varnam poor who was born on december 8
1812 in endo remain staying true to his
name henry's background was rather poor
henry and his brother john were the
first people in their family to go to
college and they both got a law degree
after graduation the two combined forces
and established a local law firm in
bangor maine this was a rather lucrative
career and the brothers made sure to
spend and invest the money as
effectively as possible for example in
the 1840s means rapidly growing timber
industry caught their attention they
invested heavily into the industry which
ended up making them quite wealthy and
now that they were wealthy the brothers
started to pursue what they truly wanted
for john this meant continuing to grow
his wealth by becoming a business tycoon
he went ahead and spent his time
expanding maine's real network and he
quickly became the business magnate that
he dreamed of as for henry on the other
hand he was mostly content with the
world that he had already made and he
had little desire to continue chasing
money so he decided to spend his time
trying to help other everyday investors
get to his level to do this henry took
up a job at one of his brother's many
companies called the american real world
journal and he became their manager and
editor in 1849
for the next 13 years henry regularly
published articles regarding the
financial and operational state future
of american railroad companies all this
work eventually culminated into a book
called history of railroads and canals
in the united states which made its
debut in 1860 as the name suggests the
book attempted to provide a detailed
account of the entire history of us
railroads and canals after publishing
this book henry felt that he had done
enough community service and decided to
follow his brother's footsteps deeper
into the business world in 1862 he took
on a role as a governor commissioner of
union pacific railroad and he was
promoted to secretary his very first
year but henry wasn't all that impressed
or excited about the job and would end
up leaving soon after henry returned to
spreading his knowledge about railroads
but this time he decided to join forces
with his son henry william poor together
they founded hv and hw pornco and in
1868 the company published two railroad
guide books which were updated on an
annual basis around this time henry's
brother john unfortunately passed away
at age 63 and this was a clear signal to
henry that he should start taking things
easy over the next decade henry slowly
stepped away from the company and let
his son take over completely
ironically though henry had many decades
left to go as he didn't end up passing
away until 1905 at age 92. so there was
no doubt that henry had lived a pretty
full life but his company porn the co
was just half of what would eventually
become s p global
moving into the 1900s we saw more people
enter the stock market and the creation
of new instruments called indicators
nowadays investors who solely rely on
indicators are often laughed at given
that the usefulness of indicators is
usually overstated nonetheless back in
the late 1800s and early 1900s stock
market indicators became all the crates
and amongst the plethora of indicators
that were created we saw one from a man
named charles dowd charles was a
journalist who had dedicated his entire
career to bringing transparency to
financial journalism he wanted to
demystify the stock market by making
financial news easily digestible every
day after markets closed charles put
together a two-page summary of the day's
financial news called the customer's
afternoon letter this newsletter became
so popular that in 1889 charles decided
to start his own publishing company you
might have heard of this one it's called
the wall street journal while the wall
street journal has become a stable
publishing company today no one really
associates it with charles something
that people do associate with charles
however is of course the dow jones
industrial average charles created the
stock market indicator in 1896 he wanted
to allow his readers to gage the health
of the stock market by just looking at
one number the dao has since become the
most cited stock market measure in
history unfortunately charles never
witnessed this as he passed away in 1902
but his invention would become the basis
of the second half of sntp global in
1906 we saw the creation of standard
statistics company which was heavily
inspired by pornco
instead of solely publishing about the
financial state of railroad companies
though standard posted about the
financial state of everything except for
the railroad industry given the lack of
financial news at the time this simple
alteration was quite successful
about 17 years later standard decided to
draw inspiration from another financial
icon which was of course charles doubt
standard couldn't just copy the dow
jones though they needed something to
make them unique so standard decided to
simply beat the dao in terms of quantity
instead of creating an index based on 30
companies standard decided to create an
indicator that encompassed 233 companies
and 26 industries surely this was a much
better indicator than the dow simple
statistics would tell you that the
greater the sample size the more
accurate the result over the next few
decades standard also created other
indices such as the 90 stock composite
price index which further grew the
popularity of the company by 1941 it
became clear that standard was here to
stay
so poor in the code decided to join
forces with them and together they
created standard and pores
over the next 16 years their indices
went to the moon as the stock market
roared after world war ii this garnered
the company's indicators more attention
than ever before and in 1957 they came
out with their crown jewel the s p 500.
standard and poor didn't stay standard
and poor for very long though in 1966
mcgraw-hill the company that tortured us
through high school and college went
ahead and purchased tender and poor they
kept the naming scheme of the s p 500
and other indices but they changed the
name of the company itself to reflect
the parent company mcgraw-hill despite
how popular snpp indices were they
didn't really make the company any money
at the time no investor or hedge fund
cared to invest in index funds index
funds were seen as garbage meant for
unsophisticated investors in fact
vanguard's founder john c bogo was
laughed at for trying to create a
company centered on index funds now this
doesn't mean that investors didn't pay
attention to the s 500 they paid very
close attention to the index because it
was a great indicator and the perfect
benchmark to beat in other words indices
were highly respected as an indicator
but not respected at all as an
investment considering this it made no
sense for mcgraw hill to create an index
fund based on their indices
instead they decided to leverage the
brand name of sndp and generate revenue
by providing other financial services
one of these endeavors was the custom
directory established in 1969 the
directory assigns each financial
instrument a special nine-digit number
that makes it much easier to clear and
settle traits today the directory
contains references to 57 million
financial instruments around the world
and it has become the standard for
clearing and settling trades mcgraw-hill
also spent significant effort in
expanding smp's credit rating system
which has become one of the most
respected credit rating systems in the
world mcgraw-hill also got sndp into the
market analysis sector for a fee sndp
will provide customers with a detailed
intelligence and analysis reports into
whichever financial market they choose
despite all the progress they were
making with snp macro hill was still an
education company at their core and they
spent the majority of their effort in
trying to grow the education side of the
company for example in 1986 mcgraw
bought out their largest education
competitor called the economy company
this acquisition made mcgraw the largest
education publisher in the us
all this growth with education put their
financial business on the back burner
but this would all change with the turn
of the century
ever since the early 2000s people
started to come to a realization while
index funds were boring and
unsophisticated they were also safe and
reliable and nothing made this clearer
than 90 of internet companies going
bankrupt but the pain wasn't just
limited to speculative internet startups
even the biggest most established tech
companies struggled to return to their
dot-com peaks and some of them like
cisco and intel still haven't beaten
their dot-com peaks considering this
investors became more open to the idea
of index fund investing you might not
make massive returns but you can be sure
that after a recession or even a
depression the indices will post new
all-time highs people also started to
argue that passive investing was even
better than active investing one of the
biggest proponents of this argument was
of course warren buffett in 2007 warren
buffett placed a 1 million bet that
index funds would outperform hedge funds
in the next decade warren ended up
winning the bet and this was the final
green light for investors to pile into
index funds not only were index funds
safer and less stressful but they
literally posted better returns than
hedge funds and even warren buffett
himself now just because these guys
couldn't beat the market doesn't mean
that it's impossible to beat the market
many investors have been beating the
market for decades like jim simons but
this requires a combination of work risk
and luck that doesn't seem to be worth
it for most anyway all the new interest
surrounding index funds brought in more
revenue than ever before for mcgraw hill
in the meantime their education business
wasn't doing nearly as well
mcgraw had just spent several years
trying to grow an online study network
called greatguru.com but this never took
off so mcgraw hill decided to ditch
education and go all in on sndp in 2012
they sold their education division to
apollo global management for 2.5 billion
dollars in cash following the sale the
company changed their name to
mcgraw-hill financial and they used this
name for the next couple of years
but by 2016 it was clear that everyone
knew the company for the s p indices so
they changed their name to s to b global
since then sntp global has grown into a
massive conglomerate that profits 2 to
2.5 billion every quarter but the most
ironic part about the business is their
stock price their entire brand is
centered on the idea that index fund
investing is superior to active
investing yet their stock price has
crushed the s p 500 since the financial
crisis growing over two thousand percent
which is roughly four times the s p 500
maybe it'll settle down over time but
we'll just have to see
do you guys prefer to pick stocks or
just invest in the s p 500 comment that
down below
also drop a like if you're a hodler and
of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one